Axel what's up buddy hey how's it going
rich and uh how's it going people of the
internet people of the internet
uh just out of curiosity I'm gonna kill
a two in the back here but um for me
from just your purse personally and from
your independent research yeah
um what where has been the most
successful situations when it does come
time to meeting an LTR or meeting and
meeting in general because I've been
looking at well we look at apps we look
at people meeting in person and to me
based on how lazy the interaction
typically is in apps the fact that
you're able to to meet people in person
does seem like you're going to have a
bit more of a genuine connection when it
comes to that but based on your research
and the people that you've come across
and how successful some people are well
yeah like you said like where do you go
to find an LTR and you don't really go
anywhere to find an LT are you spin
plates you have to date a lot of women
let the cream rise to the top and then
pick from you know the best that's out
there right like after you start dating
a bunch of women non-monogamously in a
simultaneous fashion at some point
they're going to start being yo Axel I
dig your Vibe where do we stand right
like where is this going like what are
we you know let's start doing stuff like
that you never open that conversation
women have to open that conversation
okay if you want her to be girlfriend
type of material you want her to open
that conversation if you're the guy
that's like it's funny I was I was
looking at some uh posts earlier today
and it said something like I'm 19 she's
20. uh we've hung out four times
together and been dating for two weeks
is it too early to ask her to be my
girlfriend sort of thing and it's like
that's how most thirsty guys think right
it's like well where do I go to find the
girlfriend how do I you know like find
that check it's like you don't she will
come to you choose women that choose you
right spin plates let the cream rise to
the top let them hit you up with Where
Do We Stand where's this going what are
we and then from that point on then you
can be like well that's when you start
making your decisions you know I mean
but that shouldn't happen within two
weeks it shouldn't even happen with two
months it should be a few months down
the road
and even when it does happen
you can decide what that relationship is
going to look like I mean do you want to
have a one-on-one monogamous
relationship do you want to keep options
open what is it that you want to do
because at the end of the day you're
going to be the guy that's spoiled for
choice right because you've got options
you've got multiple women
my my case is that like on like for
example on on some of these dating apps
the success rate in terms of like making
matches it's uh it can be up there but
in terms of where those conversations go
going forward or just the interest level
it's typically
like I'm not sure if it's just like the
um like if the market is oversaturated
so to speak so you have a lot more
whether it's on both sides there's more
options for people to pick and choose
from so it comes down to how do you
differentiate yourself and one of it of
course is from what you've been talking
about is leveling up yourself and being
the best you can be and everything else
it kind of comes along with it but
um
in in on dating apps in general it just
seems like that that there's so many
people that are that are on there to
differentiate yourself further yeah you
saw some of the complaints that some of
these women had on the dating apps
earlier on in the show where they're
talking about like a four percent close
rate or I went on I don't know anywhere
from 50 to 780 dates you can't get the
truth out of them sometimes even with
the math but
um so how how old are you let's start
with a few stats 33 and what do you do
for a living uh work as a PM project
manager okay and as far as income and
the percentage brackets like where you
at of West Coast I'm in the uh six
figures Okay so
top forty percent thirty percent like
high six figures those six figures like
where yeah top ten percent okay so top
ten percent
um where in the west coast are you uh
Vancouver okay so you're in Canada
um how tall are you six feet what do you
weigh uh 220. you look a little bit
heavy in the face and neck yeah
definitely okay well that's going to
give you an advantage if you can lose
that you know like that round like you
actually become more Handsome when you
lose the weight like I got Jaren here in
the um waiting area and he used to be a
fat dude right and he became incredibly
that like way better looking losing all
the fat on his face like when you look
at the pictures of the heavier version
of himself he didn't look good at all
like as soon as you start to get your
get yourself down to a heavy like
reasonable way at six foot 220 you
probably are gonna look better around
190 195 pounds even if you're like
muscular too
so that's going to help you a hell of a
lot because again I mean like if you
want to be the one that's going to be
choosing like are you looking for a
girlfriend you're looking for Mother's
stock like what's the plan or you want
to have kids like what are you trying to
do oh want to go out want to go to the
LTR route you want to have kids at some
point in time but at this point I don't
just want to knock anybody up any either
it's just okay you know want to have
that proper proper household so to speak
yeah so like Axel like I'll put it
straight through like you're a good
looking guy like you've got you know
like a good look you got nice hair you
know your facial hair fills in nice you
lose that 20 to 30 pounds of like fat
that you're carrying around
start you know looking a lot more
masculine muscular strong confident
standing up straight when you approach
women when you've got dates going on
when you're swiping likes if you're
going to use dating apps it's almost all
photography if you don't have good
photographs of yourself women aren't
going to swipe right it's not about your
personality it's not about anything else
like 90 95 of their of their swiping
habits is based on generally the first
picture and if you don't have a good
first picture and a guy like me comes
along baldu with a nice beard [ __ ]
you know with a great first picture
guaranteed that I'll get the right swipe
and you won't doesn't matter that I'm
older doesn't matter they don't have any
hair I can I can take dope ass pictures
and get matches all day long if I want
them right so I mean I talk about that
in my book right like there's an entire
chapter that talks about those details
the kind of photographs to have you know
where you want to place them what kind
of bio but it's just a numbers game and
you got a bit of work to do in yourself
like if you rate yourself on a scale of
one to ten with 10 being the absolute
best version yourself and one being the
worst version where do you put yourself
oh definitely six right now okay and I
tell and I tell guys not to date if
they're a seven or lower like don't even
use dating apps if you're seven or lower
because you're gonna get [ __ ] results
so if you're placing yourself at a six
and you know to be fair most guys are
pretty tough on themselves right you
know when they come to rate like guys
tend to rate themselves lower women tend
to rate themselves higher you see what
I'm saying yeah yeah you got torture
here in the chat saying that you're an
eight
okay well I appreciate that so
like yeah do you have some work to do
for sure you know like you're you're
kind of coming at it from a scarcity
mindset like how do I get the girlfriend
and it really should be like okay well
how do I get the girls
to date me and then start asking me
questions like where do we stand and
then putting myself in a position where
I've got to choose between Becky Sarah
and you know Crystal or whatever you see
what I'm saying you know like there's a
little bit of confidence missing there
for you somebody just said here in the
chat you know a little bit more
confidence
all right not good to hear good oh good
words for sure so I'll take take that
and uh run with it yeah you'll be fine
bro you'll be fine cool hey guys I
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational Essentials for health
immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out